pro-trump podcaster Jesse Kelly tweeted
that the country needs a dictator a
dictator and that a dictator is coming
you know I have to tell you to some
degree I respect them just saying it
like it is when you look at Trump and
you see how he's so disgusted with
Democratic Western leaders like the
leaders of France and Germany and others
and he's so enamored with dictators
Putin duterte at one point in time Kim
Jong-un erdogan and others I could give
you the full list I would rather them
just say I'd kinda rather the US be a
dictatorship I'd rather be able to
remain president indefinitely I'd rather
be able to do all those things I would
respect him more if they just came out
and said it and so while Jesse Kelly is
an authoritarian lunatic I'm glad that
he's just saying he would like a
dictatorship